gather three of your favorite friends
and get ready to save tertium from chaos
here is everything you need to know
about Warhammer 40K dark tide
Warhammer 40K dark tide is a first
person Co-op shooter with a gameplay
similar to that of Warhammer vermintide
2. developer fat shark's previous game
you play as one character in a squad of
four working together to survive a
grueling campaign full of monsters and
villains while completing objectives
however unlike vermintide 2 which was
almost exclusively melee focused dark
tide features what the developers have
called hybrid combat and Promises a more
even split between ranged and melee
attacks mixing the two kinds of combat
together meant that fat shark had to
think about how to add range to enemies
to scenarios without them feeling tacked
on or unbalanced in various encounters
that meant creating a cover system that
enemies could adhere to so soldiers
aren't just standing around waiting for
you to shoot them enemy soldiers are
also designed to try to group together
to create a unified front whereas male
enemies are likely to come from all over
the place that means that soldiers feel
like they're fighting you intelligently
while helping prevent the mix of melee
and ranged combat from becoming so
chaotic that is confusing and unfun
level design was also a major part of
making dark Tides fights more fun
without being unbalanced like in the
vermintide games dark tide uses an AI
director behind the scenes which
dictates where and when enemies show up
to fight players and what types of
enemies those forces include but that
means the developers never know exactly
what will happen in a given battle in an
interview with Gamespot fat shark's head
of design Victor magnussen said we just
have to make sure that throughout the
missions there are all these
possibilities that could happen if the
AI director system decides to adhere to
it aside from a cover system dark Tides
more Dynamic combat encounters led to
the inclusion of Sprint vaulting
Advanced recoil suppressive fire and a
regenerating Shield called toughness
that will only protect you if you stay
close to your teammates at launch you'll
have your pick of one of four classes
these include the Veteran's Sharpshooter
a class that specializes in range combat
Sharpshooters start the game with a
Cantrell Mark 7 last gun as well as a
standard issue shovel this class is a
good choice against Elites and special
enemies has increased ammo capacity and
can slow their movement for increased
weak spot damage accuracy and handling
the psycho Psy kinetic a class that can
manipulate Imperium forces with their
mind and use it to pop enemy skulls like
balloons however psychers are not just
limited to their minds they also get a
stub revolver and a combat sword the
Zealot preacher a class that specializes
in high damage melee attacks damage that
increases based on their
Health the preacher is effective against
armored enemies has high melee attack
speed and can Dash forward for the upper
hand in combat this class starts out
with a combat ax as well as an auto
pistol lastly there's the ogre and skull
breaker another melee focused class with
increased damage in that category
they're good against hordes effective at
staggering and suppression and can
revive teammates faster the skull
breaker starts off the game with a pipe
club and a thumper unlike vermintide 2
these classes are not tied to specific
pre-created heroes in dark tide you have
the ability to make your own character
from the ground up you'll get to sculpt
how your character looks by adjusting
all the typical options like face shape
hairstyle and eye color but you'll also
get to pick your backstory in order to
shape your character's personality
another difference from vermintide is
that levels and missions are no longer
tied to one another and different
missions can now take place in the same
location education levels can also
include optional side objectives that
reward more loot you'll mostly get
random loot at the end of missions but
fatshard realized in vermintide that
Randomness could be a pain for players
who take on a mission over and over
again and can't seem to get the certain
type of weapon that they want to draw to
help combat this dark Tides Hub area
which includes characters to talk to and
a station to launch missions from
includes vendors where you can purchase
specific types of weapons just in case
that chain sword is refusing to drop at
the end of missions you can also take on
long-term contracts to earn yourself
better weapons fulfilling objectives to
gather currency that you can then pay
towards a piece of gear to eventually
unlock it
Warhammer 40K dark tie takes place in
the hive city of tertiium nurgle the
Lord of plague Decay and contagion has
sent parasitic entities called chaos
into that City you take control of a
convict also known as a reject who has
committed crimes against the emperor
under direct orders from the Inquisition
you're tasked with freeing tertiium of
its demons and Heretics the story was
written by Dan Abnet an author who has
written some of the biggest Warhammer
40K and Horus heresy novels as well as
other universes like Marvel DC and Tomb
Raider Dan was also co-writer of 2014's
alien isolation according to the
developer Warhammer 40K dark tide will
feature an evolving story that it hopes
can stay fresh for returning players fat
shark seems to be aiming for a more
Dynamic live service s campaign that
will continue over time also in effort
to keep the experience fresh dark type
will include over 75 000 lines of voice
dialogue that can mix up the experience
depending on the situation party
composition and other factors
[Music]
similar to Warhammer end times
vermintide and Warhammer vermintide 2
dark tide is being developed and
published by fat shark the company is
located in Stockholm Sweden and has
developed its own games as well as acted
as a subcontractor for several others
dark-eyed was first announced in July of
2020 with plans for a 2021 release
however due to difficulties during the
covid-19 pandemic the game was delayed
foreign
Warhammer 40K dark tide will release on
PC via Steam and the Microsoft store on
November 30th 2022 the Xbox series X and
S version of the game does not have a
release date at the time of this
recording however developer fat shark
stated that the Xbox version will launch
shortly after the PC one for those
looking to buy the game on PC you have
two versions to choose from there is a
standard edition listed for 39.99 as
well as an imperial Edition listed for
59.99 the Imperial Edition comes with a
special in-game backpack a mortise
veteran portrait frame 2500 aquilas the
game's in-game currency and the loyalist
pack that contains four unique class
outfits eight weapon skin patterns one
set of headgear and a ogren body tattoo
pre-ordering any version of the game
will get you a special weapon trinket as
well as a Vanguard of the epirium
portrait frame game Warhammer 40K dark
tide will also be available day one on
Xbox game pass for PC
for guides tips tricks and the review
make sure to check out gamespot.com
[Music]